il ya un an québec modifié la loi sur la
conservation du patrimoine naturel pour
y inclure un nouveau concept celui des
aires protégées d'initiatives
autochtones sur la côte nord la
communauté innue de pessamit tu as
décidé de saisir l'occasion pour
réclamer la protection d'une partie de
son territoire ancestral au centre du
projet il y à la sauvegarde du caribou
forestier et de la culture inouïe
à
e
[Musique]
pessamit est une communauté innu de 4000
membres située au bord du saint laurent
sur la côte nord au québec
aujourd'hui une dizaine de paix ça
miaule nout se prépare dans la bonne
humeur pour une mission importante
documenter une partie de leur territoire
en vue d'y créer une aire protégée
l'objectif sauver l'habitat des derniers
caribou du nitassinan la terre
ancestrale désigne
une fois l'itinéraire établi c'est le
grand départ
direction le nord
la forêt boréale et le réservoir pic
mois galles
[Musique]
e
trois aînés participe à l'expédition des
anges saints-anges
philippe roques et robert dominique
au cours des prochains jours leur
connaissance du territoire et des
savoirs traditionnels vont être utile
pour faire avancer le projet d'aires
protégées
tout au long du trajet la rivière
betsiamites le convoi s'arrête pour y
jeter un coup d'oeil
c'est une rivière patrimoniale pour nos
autres c'est sa note votre auto routes
l'eau à l'époque ne nous en sert qu'à
qui monte vers le territoire
mais la rivière betsiamites a beaucoup
changé depuis cette époque où les innu
vivait une existence nomade sur ce
territoire
d'abord dans les années 50 on ya
construit une centrale hydroélectrique
et puis ces dernières années
d'importantes coupes forestières sont
venus changer complètement le paysage
est menacée l'habitat des caribous
un camion chargé de croix le qui se
passe expo qui étaient récoltées sur le
territoire en fait pleurer
territoire de chasse et des boisés
avec une femme à l'hôtel
tout les beaux-arts brevet sur le
territoire
ça s'envole
vers la mer ça va devenir un papier
à l'organisons conserver de temps pour
faire des tas royal on faire des boîtes
chauffard pour faire des raquettes pour
faire des rames pitt sont
les innus de pessamit tu veulent se
réapproprier leur territoire ancestral
pendant plusieurs années sinon on était
aussi de leur territoire par un
développement à l'eau qui nous exclut
est faite nous autres l'important
maintenant c'est d'essayer de
sauvegarder cette culture l'eau ce lien
avec le territoire conquis très
important
après trois heures de route le convoi
arrive à destination
demain le travail va commencer
[Musique]
la nouvelle aire protégée serait ancré
autour du réservoir du mois gamme à
l'intérieur du nitassinan des innus de
pessamit
elle couvrirait une superficie de 2000
761 kilomètres carrés et chevaucheraient
la limite entre le saguenay lac saint
jean et la côte-nord
c'est marie hélène rousseau qui est
responsable du projet pour le conseil
des innus de pessamit tu avec eric
canapé et les aînés elle cherche à
documenter comment le pic mois gagnent
et le caribou forestier sont intimement
liées à l'identité de la nation innu
niveau de nuit donc s'il vous plaît
et on aime cette chanson beto da
à moto et la pétillante elle leur
donnait le ton en ukraine où il ne veut
ni belle ni au tout
cette transmission des connaissances des
aînés est nécessaire pour réaliser leurs
projets d'aires protégées
d'initiatives autochtones en 2021 le
québec a créé ce statut particulier de
protection les premières nations peuvent
désormais proposer des projets sur leur
territoire afin de conserver des
éléments de la biodiversité et aussi des
valeurs culturelles qui leur sont
associées à protéger qui est faite pour
l'homme pauline ou en fait c'est la
protéger et moyens d'un spina qui est
créé par et pour les personnels pour
s'assurer justement qu'on puisse ses
protégés à perpétuité au moins un
endroit dans lequel on peut poursuivre
les pratiques traditionnelles pour les
transmettre aux générations futures
sur le réservoir pic mois gagnent les
aînés ont permis de retrouver des lieux
que leurs ancêtres nomades ont foulé
durant des millénaires des sites oublié
où il pêchait trapet et chasser comme la
porte du diable
[Musique]
ou encore le grand portage où subsiste
toujours des traces de sentiers sur les
arbres
le mode de vie se pratique sur le
territoire la transmission des
connaissances via son mode de vie depuis
toutes les activités qui en découlent se
transmettent ici la langue qui est
associée à ces différentes activités le
aussi se pratique ici
[Musique]
protéger la langue et la culture d i
know passe aussi par la protection du
caribou forestier
celui qu'il nomme minaj kuachuk est un
animal sacré au centre de leur existence
depuis la nuit des temps
le carré mousse l'animal qui nous aurait
permis de détention aujourd'hui pendant
des milliers d'années
le caribou on nourrit nous en sert des
habits des outils au niveau spirituel
c'était un animal important aussi ça
représente qui on est le lien qu'on a
avec le territoire notre langue notre
culture nous savoir traditionnel
ce que nous ancêtres ont vécu qui ont
marché sur ce territoire c'est ce que
c'est ce que ça représente c'est très
important pour nous autres
mais la situation du caribou forestier
se dégrade rapidement
depuis 2005 il est désigné comme espèce
vulnérable au québec en 2020 un
inventaire aérien a révélé que la
population du secteur pitt mois gagnent
était en baisse on y comptait plus que
225 individus
les résultats nous indiquent les taux
vraiment précaire la population il des
taux de recrutement qui font vraiment
très faire bien très inquiétant
pour endiguer la baisse du cheptel de
caribous dans le nitassinan de pessamit
les i nous ont volontairement arrêté de
les chasser depuis 15 ans mais ce n'est
pas suffisant
le caribou est un des espèces important
de la chaîne pour les i nous parce que
parce que ça a été toujours notre grand
nourrissent c'est lui qui nous
nourrissent et c'est lui qui nous a mis
où on est aujourd'hui
c'est comme si le caribou nous criait
aidez moi je suis en train de
disparaître comme les innu 1 sont en
train de disparaître notre langue est en
train de disparaître
[Musique]
les innu sont inquiets
le caribou forestier est menacée de
toutes parts et c'est la perte de son
habitat qui est le principal facteur de
son déclin on peut pointer du doigt les
changements climatiques les feux de
forêt les ravages causés par la tordeuse
des bourgeons de l'épinette et
l'augmentation de la villégiature
mais le coeur du problème c'est
l'exploitation forestière les travaux de
l'industrie ont considérablement modifié
la composition de la forêt ce qui
représente tout un défi pour les
caribous en hiver le caribou y voit se
nourrir de lichens qui est fait sur
quelqu'un qui a une coop au rsa at ça
prend un certain temps avant que la
nourriture tels que le likoud se
rétablit pas ce week-end on le retrouve
surtout le dans l'est dans les vieilles
forêts
les prédateurs sont aussi de plus en
plus nombreux
il ya aussi que la coupe forestière et à
la même des chemins forestiers sur le
territoire puis là les chemins
forestiers sont utilisés par le loup ce
qui fait que le loup peut plus
facilement
attaquer le karité
les coupes total comme celles ci font
donc craindre le pire aux signaux depuis
quatre ans ou 5 à l'eau à peu près
l'euro on vit dans cet environnement
avast et c'était une foire et il y avait
des des portages très anciens qui ont
utilisé dans pour aller chasser al et
râper aller d'un endroit un nom mais
depuis donc coupé puis on se sent
complètement démunis
pour réussir la mise en place de leurs
aires protégées les i nous devront
convaincre l'industrie forestière de
cesser les coupes sur une partie du
territoire mais c'est loin d'être gagné
fini par difficile de créer une aire
protégée dans la forêt aménagée parce
que la priorité du gouvernement et
beaucoup basé sur l'économie puis donc
mais l'impact sur la possibilité forrest
a fait seul frein numéro un à la
création d'un protéger reste que la
crainte légitime de perdre des emplois
en région est bien présente
on peut aussi comprendre
leur demande leur position où il est il
ya des emplois oui c'est important des
gens veulent travailler nos gens veulent
travailler aussi mais
moi je demande à ces gens-là de comprend
de nous comprendre aussi notre culture
l'autre tout ce qu'on fait d'un en forêt
cette importance aussi que les gens
reconnaissent eux c'est important pour
nous au
moins je pense que c'est pas juste d'un
parent lui fois j
-c panahi 13e ou 14e étage les grandes
villes qu'on décide se font insulter red
bull pouvoir pour voir la réalité
comme vous en trouverez la réalité
aujourd'hui
c'est triste
le conseil des innus de pessamit tu veux
assurer la gouvernance et la gestion de
la nouvelle aire protégée
les i nous souhaite aussi arrimer leurs
projets à la future stratégie caribou du
gouvernement du québec celle ci prévoit
établir des territoires où les habitats
des caribous seront préserver ou
restaurer en même temps les activités
forestières ils seront encadrés
on espère que les gens vont comprendre
que l'importance du caribou dans notre
culture pour aussi les écosystèmes dans
les habite au ski on retrouve le karim
ou ben c'est important de garder ces
territoires l'os et ses écosystèmes la
peau pour le futur pour le futur de nos
jeunes de pour tout le monde sport pas
juste pour les et nous c'est ça va
profiter à tous
après des siècles de discrimination et
de racisme à l'endroit des premières
nations l'heure de la réconciliation à
ce lien
[Musique]
j'ai mûri
il faut dire la vérité aujourd'hui
on est en période de réconciliation
entre nous le gouvernement fédéral le
gouvernement québécois rrq disque oui à
la réconciliation
mais il faut qu'il démontre il faut
qu'on ait des preuves on veut du concret
on veut voir le vraiment que ces
gouvernements leur agissent pour pour ce
qu'ils ont dit ça veut dire la
réconciliation depuis le premier contact
oignons en faisait des traités d'amitié
on faisait des alliances
c'est ce qu'on roule encore aujourd'hui
[Musique]
on se côtoie tous les jours mais on on
se connaît pas il ya tellement de gens
qui nous connaissent pas commun qu'on
peut vous apporter en tant que société
les non autochtones
n'ayez pas peur de visiter les villages
indiens
allez-y faites connaissance avec les i
nous avec tous les et du canada n'ayez
pas peur de pénétrer dans les réserves
oublier l'histoire du canada ce jour là
il faut pas nous
nous exterminer excusez le monde il n'y
a ni
papier ni
yacht
[Musique]